-It's in the cloud.
It's in the cloud.
O.J.! It's in the cloud!
-Mm-hmm.
-Yeah, naw, naw, naw.
Run, O.J.! Run!
♪♪
-Welcome back to "Late Night,"
everybody.
We're here with Daniel Kaluuya,
Keke Palmer, Brandon Perea,
Director Jordan Peele.
That was a clip from "Nope."
It's about all you want
to see in a clip.
I feel like you don't want
to see much more.
Because this is not a movie
you want spoiled
before you actually go
to the theater.
"Nope" is a wonderful title.
How -- When did you
come up with it?
And did you know
when you came up with it
that you had a winner?
-I mean, it was pretty late.
I was -- I wrote the movie
with a different title in mind.
I had different things
I was trying out.
When I hit "Nope," it just made
sense because the movie,
it just -- it's not even a --
it's like a concept.
You know,
it's one of those films
that I think just sort of
needs its own type of title.
So, yeah, yeah, I knew.
-I remember when he talked
about it with us both,
and I was like, "That's it!"
Do you remember that?
-No, I do not remember.
[ Laughter ]
I don't remember one bit.
I was like, "'Nope' is amazing.
'Nope' is amazing."
And another time Keke was like,
"I like that one!"
-No, I didn't --
[ Talking over each other ]
-That's a lie.
-Don't tell --
Don't tell the secrets.
-I didn't know that it was
called "Nope."
And then I saw it, like,
on the action clapper board.
And I was like, "Oh, he's not
revealing the title yet."
I just did not know
it was "Nope."
And then I heard...
-Yeah, every day,
they go to Jordan
and they're like, "Did you
come up with a title yet?"
-And he would say, "Nope."
-Eventually they just
started putting it down.
-Yeah. And it worked out.
So, you -- We talked about this.
You are a huge horror fan.
But, also, do you believe
in the sort of extraterrestrial?
-Absolutely without a doubt.
-Okay.
-Come on. You've got to believe
there's something out there.
They could be out there.
-Okay.
Do not besmirch my audience.
[ Laughter ]
-But they're cool.
They're not blowing us up, man.
-Yeah, that's true.
They've been here
the whole night.
We can't give them a hard time.
Now, you -- I heard that you --
The existence of koalas informs
how you feel about aliens.
-Yeah, because koalas exist.
So if there's a koala, there's
got to be something up there.
It's like kangaroos.
There's Chihuahuas.
They're, like,
weird-looking animals.
If you really look,
they're very weird,
and they've got weird names.
So then, you think, what,
in Jupiter, they ain't got,
like, a koala --
like, a koala going...
I just think, like -- Yeah.
If there's kangaroos,
there have got to be aliens.
-Okay. Gotcha.
That's a very --
I respect the science
behind this decision.
Jordan gave you
some film assignments.
-Yeah.
-This was --
What were some of the movies
he wanted you to watch, Brandon?
-So, the film list that I got
on the day I got the job
was "Close Encounters
of the Third Kind,"
"Jaws," "2001: A Space Odyssey,"
"Alien,"
and "No Country For Old Men."
And I was like,
"What does this mean?"
And I -- So, I took the job
without knowing what the heck
the movie was about.
There was no synopsis released.
A month and a half later,
I get a text message from Peele
on Christmas Day
just being like,
"Merry Christmas."
And it was the script.
So I accepted the job
not knowing what I was doing,
but I was like,
"It's Jordan Peele.
I'm going to do whatever
he wants me to do."
And then I read the script,
and I was just floored.
-I know.
-I gave them some movies
to watch because I had to stall.
I had to rewrite the script.
-He did.
-I had to figure it out.
-Yeah, some of those
are very long movies.
I noticed.
-Very long movies.
I was ready to add some.
Yeah, but -- You know,
I do believe in UFOs.
I'm just -- I want to say that.
Or I believe in aliens.
And I believe in life
that is not us in this universe.
And I -- Sometimes I think
if aliens came down, like,
I would turn on all of y'all.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, interesting.
-Like in a heartbeat.
And it's not -- It's not
because I don't like you.
But I feel like
there might be room
for, like, one prime human
on the alien...
-So he made a movie.
-And so I made a movie.
I would make that move
is all I'm saying.
I don't --
-So you basically made a movie
that you would have to show them
if it ever happened.
-I just don't know --
If there's aliens out there,
I already don't know
whose side I'm on.
That's all I'm saying.
-That's very honest of you
to come right out and say it.
So, Keke, I've heard
that you based your character,
Emerald, on a couple
of people --
Marty McFly from "Back
to the Future" and your dad.
-Yeah!
-Here's your dad right there.
-My dad's the best.
-Is that premiere night?
-Literally
that's premiere night.
-Alright. That's great.
-And I love his little outfit,
his little tie.
My dad is the sweetest man
in the world.
And I really did --
I admired my dad all growing up.
And my character, she's so cool
and confident in who she is.
And she also admired her brother
and her dad.
And so I just felt like,
"Yeah, let's pull from that."
-That's a nice way to pull from.
Daniel, I've talked on the show
that my parents give me feedback
on everything I do.
They watch every show.
I have no complaints,
but they do give me notes.
I've heard your mom
does the same.
-She gives me notes, yeah.
A lot of notes. A lot of notes.
-The difference is, you know,
I've got a show tomorrow night.
So, like, they can give me notes
and I can fix it the next night.
But, like, the movie's done.
-I know, so it's not --
I can't do anything about it.
"That wasn't..."
"I can't --
I can't reshoot that now.
It's released."
-But do you like it?
I mean, obviously, it comes
from a place
of love and support, right?
-Yeah, it's --
She's actually told me
not to talk about her
in public anymore.
She's like, "No, don't do that,
don't do that."
But I asked her about "Nope"
and she said, "No comment."
-Really?!
-Yeah.
-That doesn't --
-I'll speak to you later.
-She doesn't want
you exposing her.
She doesn't want you
exposing her.
-She knows what I'm like.
Do it after the press run.
-Oh, I see, right.
-Early September,
I'll get reviewed.
-There you go.
Brandon,
you have a special skill
that did not turn up
in the film.
But this is an incredible
piece of trivia
about you
that I found out today.
You were the youngest
professional roller skater --
-That break-dances
on roller skates.
Yeah, so I turned pro
at the youngest age.
I think I turned pro
at 14 years old.
No one has done that.
I mean, break-dancing
on roller skates is very --
It's a tiny sport.
People play ping-pong
on a tennis court
far more than they break-dance
in roller skates.
-Okay, gotcha.
-So it's a very niche thing.
-So you were a professional
break-dancing roller skater?
-Yeah.
-Okay, got[ Chatter ].
-Yeah, so I --
-I love it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-So, I can do some things.
I can do some things.
-We were actually -- We heard
that you could do a backflip.
-Yeah, I can do a backflip.
-But we were also told --
When I asked the producer,
they said,
"Don't let him
because of insurance."
-It's fine. It's fine.
-And I shouldn't say this,
but our cue-card guy
already fell today.
-Oh, no.
-Are you alright?
-Is that him over there?
-Yeah, he's alright.
-Are you from --
-Yeah, that's Wally.
Don't take your mask off, Wally.
"Oh, the 'SNL' host knows me.
I got to take my mask off."
-There's video clips,
so I can prove it.
-Alright. Everybody can go
watch video clips
of Brandon
where we are not at liability.
So please watch
and enjoy those.
And we will be right back with
more "Late Night," everybody.